[Music]
today Mariah made history and we were
there a sheet solidified it in cement
it's an honor to be here and I'm I hope
I can walk in these shoes that's all I
can say you chose some Louboutins
yes I did brand-new and so we'll have
them forever how do you choose like when
they're gonna be there forever a teacher
styling me me immortalized Mariah was
honored and true Hollywood tradition
today hands and strappy sandals feet and
cement at the famous TCL Chinese Theatre
good friend director Lee Daniels brought
the diva out on stage and proud
boyfriend Bryan Tanaka was there
snapping pics but twins rock and roll
missed see mom get down the dirty at the
legendary theater Mariah told me they
were in school one of these days though
hopefully they'll see it Mariah who got
her star on the Walk of Fame back in
2015 already had idol status but this
air money was extra special what does
this moment mean to you I'm humbly I'm
here I'm just like I'm so happy this is
a childhood dream
[Music]